اهلا بكم الى التفاصيل اتهم وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ديمتريكوليبا روسيا بشني هجوم
صاروخيا كثيف استهدف عمدا المناطق السكنيه
قبل ذلك اعلن عمده كييف مقتل شخص واصابه
اخرين جر انفجارات دوت في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيت بعد غارات صاروخيه روسيه
مكثفه وقالت رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان فندقا في
كييف تضرر جر الانفجارات فيما اظهرت صور
متداوله تصاعد اعمده الدخان بالقرب من
محطه الكهرباء في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بدوره قال نائب بالبرلمان الاوكراني
اندادات الطاقه توقفت مؤقتا بعد ضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه وبالتزامن مع ذلك ايضا
اعلن عمده نيكولايف جنوب البلاد وقوع
انفجارات كما حضر السكان من ضربات صاروخيه
جديده
هذا واصدر رئيس الروسي بالادمير بوتين
قرارا بانشاء نظام لتدريب المتخصصين في
تطوير وانتاج المسيارات واوضح ان الكرملين
في بيان له ان بوتين امر ايضا بانشاء لجنه
حكوميه لتطوير المصيرات برئاسه نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسيه اندريه بن صوف
الى ذلك اكد وزير الدفاع الروسيه وحتميه
انتصار قوات بلاده في العمليه العسكريه
باوكرانيا هذا وقالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه ان القصف الصاروخي الذي تشونه
القوه الروسيه منذ اكتوبر الماضي هدفه
استنفاذه الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
لكل مقاتل روسيه
للخدمه اتمنى للجميع دوام الصحه بمناسبه
العام الجديد اتمنى لهم معنويه مرتفعه
وعلاقات طيبه مع الزملاء وبالتاكيد سماء
صافيه
اوكرانيا
لجنه الانفصاليه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه والخدمات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه حسب اعلام الروسيه واثر
داخل المخبا على صاروخ موجه مضاد للدبابات
ومدفع رشاش ثقيل وقذفات قنابل ار بي جي
بالاضافه الى قضاء هجوميه صاروخيه والغام
مضاده للافراد واكثر من 50 قنبله وذخائر
لاسلحه مختلفه
هذا هو حضر مركز الدراسات بالكونجرس
الامريكي من الطباعات السلبيه لقرار توليد
انظمه دفاع جوي صاروخيه من ترانس باتريوس
الى اوكرانيا وجاء في وثيقه صادر عن
المركز ان مساله تسليم انظمه باتريوت
اضافيه الى اوكرانيا سيخلقوا تهديدات
كبيره في المرحله المقبله في اشاره الى ان
سحبها من مخزونات الاسلحه في الولايات
المتحده سيؤثر سلبا ايضا على دوريات
التدريب والتحديث في الجيش الامريكي
ولمتابعه القذف الحالي على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
الزميل حذيفه عادل مرحبا بك حذيفه يبدو من
خلفك ان الصوره تشير الى عمليات قصف
مستمره واثار لهذا القصف تفضل
نعم في العاصمه في مركز العاصمه في
الحقيقه كيف في منطقه
هذا المبنى من خلفي كما تشاهدون هذا احد
الفنادق هنا في مركز العاصمه كيف الذي
طاله القصف سقطت هنا قذيفه مباشره في هذا
المكان ونتيجه هذه القذيفه همم يعني جميع
المباني في المحيط تضررت بشكل كبير هذا
ليس القصفه الوحيد في العاصمه ايضا هنالك
موقعين اخرين تعرضا للقصف همم هنالك
ثمانيه الضحايا حتى الان همم يعني مصابين
الان يتلقون الرعايه الصحيه بينهم صحفي
ياباني ايضا اصيبه ونقل الى المستشفى
لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه قتل شخص واحد حتى
الان تشير همم الارقام التي نشرتها
السلطات ان الى مقتل رجل في متقدم في
العمر في منطقه كما
ذلك ايضا اا احدى السيدات والمتقدمه ايضا
في العمر في منزلها داخل منزلها ايضا
اصيبت ونقلت الى المستشفى همم يعني من
خلفنا او من حولنا هنا المكان يشير الى
همم عده مناطق يعني الاغلبيه من المناطق
هنا ليست سكنيه هذه مناطق تجاريه ومناطق
اعمال من الشركات وغيرها يوجد ايضا في
المحيط هنا دار الثقافه الاوكراني كما
ايضا يوجد احد المصانع همم بالقرب من هذا
الموقع حتى الان غير معلوم لماذا هذا
الاستهداف في هذا المكان طبعا تقول
السلطات الاخرانيه همم والمحللون ايضا
يتحدثون حولنا ان القذائف التي تم
استخدامها هي دقيقه جدا ولا يمكن ان تخطئ
او نسبه الخطا هي ضئيله جدا لذلك يستغربون
من ان تقع هذه القذيفه في هذا المكان طبعا
تحدث كريل تمشيكا وهو نائب رئيس ديوان
الرئاسه الاوكراني وقال ان الهدف من هذه
الهجمات هي ااا كسر عزيمه الشعب الاوكراني
وارهاب الشعب الاوكراني في عطله اعياد
الميلاد وعطله راس السنه وقال ايضا ان
انهم يعني اختاروا المواقع بدقه وهذه ليست
نتيجه اخطاء او ان القذائف اخطات اهدافها
طبعا اطلق عدد من الصواريخ
في الشارع
نعم في الحقيقه هؤلاء المتخصصين الذين
يعملون الان في على فحص المكان وجمع
الادله وبينهم الادله الجنائيه كما
تشاهدين في الصوره هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
يتقدمون هنا هؤلاء ايضا من المتخصصين في
الحقيقه لم نستطيع ان نعلم هويتهم ولكني
سمعته يتحدثون عن طبيعه الانفجار الذي حدث
هنا وقالوا ان القذيفه كانت همم يبدو انها
فجرت في الجو قبل ان تسقط في هذا المكان
والا لك حريق في المبنى وكما شاهدتي في
الصوره طبعا لم يكن هنالك حريق في المبنى
لذلك يبدو انه من المتخصصين هم الان
يفحصون المبنى والمباني
هناك مصادر اوكرانيه تقول ان تم التعبد
روسيه لقصف مناطق سكنيه ماهوله بالمدنيين
ضعنا في الصوره فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه
يعني داعيني انطلق من تصريح كريلتا مشينكه
الذي قال ان الروس يريدون ان يحتفلوا
اليوم على طاوله الاحتفال الاسري وهنا
طبعا هو يتحدث عن المسؤولين وليس عن
العامه
بان يقولوا انهم اصابوا او دمروا فندقا في
وسط العاصمه كيف او قتلوا رجلا عجوزا في
العاصمه اكيد يقول ان هذه الضربات هي
متعمده في مناطق ماهوله بالسكان لارهاب
اوكرانيين عن كسر عزيمه الاوكرانيين وطبعا
همم ايضا تحدث مخييل ابو ظلاك او صرح مخيل
بودراك وقال ان الارهاب الروسي في اعياد
الميلاد كانوا يعني متوقعا هو طبعا الرئيس
نفسه قبل ايام حذر المواطنين وقال انهم
يتوقعون ضربات صاروخيه في عطله التحيات
الميلاد من قبل الاتحاد الروسي ايضا دائما
ما يقول المسؤولين الاوكرانيين ان
المناسبات العامه والاحتفالات لن تمر
بهدوء فرصه يتعمدون ان ينفذوا ضربات في
مناطق ماهوله همم السكان طبعا ايضا يوجد
محطه او محول للكهرباء هنا في المنطقه
صغير طبعا الى يعني ايضا من الاشياء التي
لابد من ذكرها ان يمنع في بعض الاتجاهات
طبعا يمنع توجيهات الكاميرا لاسباب امنيه
تقدم الينا احد رجال الامن وطالبنا في بعض
الاتجاهات اللا نوجه الكاميره همم خاصه في
المنطقه التي يوجد فيها احد المصادر
وهذه طبعا الاجراءات امنيه نعم هذا هو
الجانب من الصوره المتعلق بها عمليات
القذف الروسي لعدد من المواقع والمناطق
كما شاهدناها الان وخاصه انها مناطق سكنيه
كما ذكر هل على الجانب الاخر من الصوره
تبدو بعض الشوارع في كيف هادئه او تستعد
للاحتفالات همم راس السنه الجديده ام ان
الخوف يخيم على السكان في العاصب
يعني اليوم شاهدت مشهد حزين يعني ساحه
القديسه صوفيا وهي الساحه الرئيسيه التي
يتم فيها الاحتفال باعياد الميلاد وفيها
شجره الميلاد اعياد الميلاد
الوحيده التي
تستمد الضوء من مولد للكهرباء وزينت
بالوان العلم الاوكراني ولكن شاهدت الشرطه
اغلقت هذه الساحه هذا حدث قبل الانفجارات
حتى شاهدت الشرطه اغلقت الساحه ومنعت
الماره من الدخول الى هذه
الساحه كانت دائما ما تكون همم يعني همم
في هذا التوقيت ليس فقط في هذا اليوم فقط
وانما منذ التاسع عشر من شهر واحد حتى بعد
راس السنه بايام تكون هذه الساحه فيها
ساحات التزلج وفيها خيام الحلوه
والمشروبات الساخنه